Scientists are using hydrogels,
which are gels mostly made up of water,
to make the next generation of soft electronics
and soft robots.
Their inspiration is nature,
where hydrogels abound.
We are mostly a hydrogel--from our tissues
and muscles to our brain.
How our softer parts combine with harder materials
like our bones and teeth makes us special.
In the lab, there are many advantages
to using synthetic hydrogels.
After all, they squash, stretch and adapt
like animals and humans do.
But the trick is how to attach hydrogels
onto all kinds of materials the way our bodies can.
Now researchers have come up with a fast
and simple method to form an instant tough bond
between hydrogels and a variety of
soft to hard materials.
Others have tried to use pure Cyanoacrylates,
the main ingredient found in super glue,
but they form brittle, non-stretchable layers.
Instead, the team’s new method uses a glue
made up of cyanoacrylate diluted with a non-solvent.
They spread this mixture onto tough hydrogels.
Mixed with the non-solvent,
the adhesive doesn’t dissolve,
which allows for a very thin layer of glue to form.
This protective shell, delays polymerization
just long enough, so when the materials
are slightly pressed together,
the non-solvent helps transport the glue
into the layers as it evaporates,
resulting in an instant tough bond.
Here, a hydrogel and an elastomer, a rubbery material,
are combined together with the new glue.
You can stretch them by 1000%
and they still don’t come apart.
And the layer of glue is so thin,
that it doesn’t disturb the mechanics of the materials.
In peel tests,
Even with the toughest hydrogels used,
the gel itself cracks but not the area where
the two materials were actually bonded together.
Next, researchers built several prototypes
using this glue.
An electronic skin complete with battery, bluetooth,
processor, heaters, and temperature sensors.
The components are bonded onto a hydrogel,
which wraps around the skin.
Because hydrogels are permeable,
you could deliver water-soluble drugs through the gel
to the surface of the skin.
Hydrogel disc replacement in the spine
is already happening.
But with the new adhesive you could assemble
this mix of hard and soft structures much more quickly.
So with tough hydrogels and this new super glue,
we could see a wave of soft technologies
and soft robots that are even more life-like.
The speed and simplicity of the process allows
for rapid prototyping,
which is great news for the exploding DIY community
of softbot makers.